في قصه نجاء اقرب للخيال اربعه اطفال
يخرجون احياء من تحطم طائره وضياع اربعين
يوم في الادغال ومتى ترد على تويتر بتطبيق
وهل النجاه من القرش ممكنه مختص حيجيبنا
اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
اللي مكتوب له عمر حيعيش السلطات
الكولومبيه عثرت على اربعه اطفال لهم
اربعين يوم ضايعين في غابات الامازون بدون
ماء او اكل الغابات هذه بتعتبر موطن
لحيوانات مفترسه وتعابين وحشرات قاتله
وزواحف وكمان مع قله الجار المخدرات ومخبا
لهم النجاه من ضياع 40 يوم وسط كل هذا
يعتبر معجزه لكن تخيلوا ان القصه مو بس
كده الاربع اطفال هدول اصلا ضاعوا في
الغابه من بعد ما تحطمت طيارتهم في الاول
من مايو وفي رحله داخليه بطياره صغيره
طاحت الطياره وتوفت امهم اللي كانت معهم
والطيار وشخص اخر بالغ قريب لهم كمان كان
معهم على الطياره يعني وجلسه السلطات 18
يوم تدور على حطام الطياره ولما لقيته
لقيت جثث الثلاث البالغين وما لقيت
الاولاد وبدات عمليات البحث الاطفال للعلم
اكبرهم بنت عمرها 13 سنه واصغرهم 11 شهر
يعني رضيع وعلى فكره كمل سنه وهم ضايعين
في الغابه وفي طفل ثالث كمان عمره تسع
سنوات وواحد اربعه سنوات امس واخيرا
لقيوهم بعد اربعين يوم طبعا وجوههم شاحبه
ايش تساعدهم نحيله لكن عايشين على بعد
خمسه كيلو مترات من موقع الحادث ونقلوا
للمستشفى
بطائرات للعاصمه
[موسيقى]
البحث عن الاولاد بدا بكل الطرق طيارات
واقمار صناعيه يعني كل الطرق الممكنه
وكانت الطائرات كمان بترمي اكل وشرب
واوراق ومنشورات فيها خرائط للخروج من
الغابات الكثيفه على امل انه الاولاد
يلاقوها وامان العثور عليهم زادت لما
لقيوا احذيه وحفاضات وفواكه ماكول نصها
بالاضافه لاثار اقدامهم وزادت اعمال
العثور عليهم اكثر واكثر لمن لقيت فرق
الانقاذ بيوت او ملاجئ يعني كده مصنوعه من
نباتات الغابه كانوا بيعملوها الاطفال
يمكن علشان يناموا او يرتاحوا فيها يعني
الاطفال عثر عليهم على بعد خمسه كيلو متر
خمسه كيلو مترات خلينا نقول من موقع
الحطام لكن عمليه البحث غطت مسافه اكثر من
2600 كيلو متر وهذه كانت حاله جدودهم
وقرايبهم لما سمعوا خبر انهم لقيومهم
وجريو الناس على المستشفى شايلين لهم اكل
وشرب ولبس
العالم كله تابع اخبار الاخوان الاربعه
وقصه نجاتهم ومن التفاصيل المؤثره جدا في
القصه حديث جده الاولاد عن انها كانت
متاكده من انه الشقيقه الكبرى وطبيعتها
المحاربه رح تنقذها هي واخواتها لانها
دائما كانت بتساعد امهم فيهم القصه شغلت
العالم وحتى الرئاسه من اول يوم كانت
متدخله فيها وشفنا الرئيس بعد ما اعلن على
تويتر انقاذ الاطفال شفناه هو وزوجته
بيزوروا الاطفال في مستشفى في العاصمه
بوغوتا ووصفهم بانهم حيدخلوا التاريخ
معنى من القاهره المغامر ورائد الاعمال
عمر سمره اهلا فيك معنا عمر طبعا يعني انت
زي ما يقولوا شايف حصتك الكبيره من هذا
النوع من
الاخبار وسمع كثير من هذه القصص وبعضها
حتى عشت مغامرات انت شخصيا يعني هل شفت
شيء بهذا الغرابه
اهلا بك يا ساره الاول
بصراحه القصه لما عرفت عنها فعلا افحمتني
يعني لان احنا بنتكلم على قدره البقاء في
مكان زي كده للكبار تعتبر شبه معجزه للمده
دي من غير اي ادوات من غير اي احتياطات
انها يعملوها اطفال وفي في حد منهم سن
الرضيع ده يعني حاجه ممكن اتخيلها
بنتكلم انه اللي مسؤوله عنهم وجلسه بتاخد
بالها منهم عمرها 13 سنه يعني انت بتقول
انه احتماليه البقاء بالنسبه للبالغين
كانت حتكون صعبه طب كيف قدروا هم كصغار
كيف ممكن نفسر انهم قدروا يتعايشوا مع
الموقف
[موسيقى]
يعني يفكروا هم طبعا لما لقوهم كانوا على
حاله يرثى لها وكانوا صحتهم مش كويسه وكم
ده طبيعي جدا
فكره ان واحد يلاقي يقدر ان هو يجيب ميه
من الادغال ويقدر ان هو يعرف يتعرف على
ايه الحاجات اللي ممكن ان هو ياكلها ما
ياكلهاش في حاجات سامه اعتقد
الاهالي الاطفال دول هم من السكان
الاصليين للامازون ودي يمكن نقطه
استوقفتني شويه لان
احنا كناس متمدنه
افتقدنا كتير قوي من يمكن
التقنيات او المواهبه للبقاء دي حاجه
مهارات البقاء كده الاساسيه لو كنا في
مكان رو او طبيعي جدا يعني
مش عارف لو الاهل علموهم ده او الجدود
علموهم ده ولكن هم اكيد البنت الكبيره
اكيد شافت ده في
القبيله فعشيره بتاعتها في جدتها في جدها
وقدرت ان هي تاخد حاجات من ده لما واحد
بيكون مولود وعايش في مناخ معين او بيئه
معينه بيقدر ان هو يستشف كثير قوي يتعلم
كتير قوي بعيدا عن قراءه الكتب وبعيدا ان
حد يشرح له هو نفسه بيعيش الموضوع ده
فاعتقد كانت اكبر
عنصر يعني خلاهم يقدروا ان هم يعدوا في
الكلام ده احنا بنتكلم في 40 يوم فده ده
كتير جدا
هل نقدر نفسر كمان الموضوع انه الناس لما
بنحطوا في هذه المواقف بتكون عندهم غريزه
البقاء زي ما بيسموها او بيكون عندهم مثلا
ادرينالين اكثر للتعايش مع الموقف
والمحاربه الموقف
يعني عايز اقول لك حاجه انا انا وعمر نور
زميلي لما يعني حصل الحادثه بينا في
المحيط الاطلنطي والمركب اتقلبت في عاصفه
شديده جدا
يعني كانت رحله البقاء او التحدي كان لمده
13 ساعه هو طبعا كان في مناخ صعب جدا
وعاصفه في وسط المحيط ولكن الواحد بيعدي
في مرحله
يعني فقدان الامل وبيعدي كمان في مرحله ان
هو مش عاوز ياخد اجراء هو مستني ان حد يجي
ينقذه وانا متخيل في في الطبيعي في المطلق
للاطفال عامه لو بنفكر في اطفالنا او
اطفال غيرنا فطبيعي جدا ان هم يفضلوا في
مكانهم مستنيين حد يجي ينقذهم بس هم ممكن
يكونوا عملوا ده الفتره صغيره بس هم عرفوا
بعد شويه ان هم لازم يتحركوا لازم يبتدوا
ان هم يشوفوا حلول لانه ممكن المكان اللي
هم فيه ما كانش امن ممكن يكون عشان يلاقوا
ميه عشان يلاقوا اكل يضطر ان هم يتحركوا
انا عارف ان هم كانوا بيستخدموا
اشياء من
الطياره الحاجات اللي كانت موجوده في
الطياره صحيح ايه طب عمر احنا واحده
فاجانا فيها بعد هذا الموضوع انه لقينا
فيه خبراء اللي هم يعني مختصين في
النجاه او البقاء يعني سيرفايفل اكسبرس
اسمهم موجودين كده ما كنا نعرف يعني
هو فعلا يتضرس يعني ممكن حد يروح او يروح
كورسوب طبعا بيتقسم الى سرفايفل في الجبال
سرفايفل في المحيط اللي احنا اضطرينا ناخد
لما عملنا المحيط طبعا بخبرتي في الجبال
قبل كده كنت عملت
واحد بيتمرن ان هو ازاي ان هو ينقذ نفسه
لو اتحط في موقف لكن كمان ازاي ان هو ينقذ
الغير لو اتحط في موقف وطبعا في ناس
عدت في التجارب دي اكتر من مره في قصه
يمكن واحنا واحنا صغيرين قصه يعني يمكن
الهامتنا كتير جدا اللي هي القصه بتاعه
اللي هي الفريق الرجبي الارجنتيني اللي
حصل
في جبال الانديز وقعد برده اسابيع
واضطر ان هم يعني في منهم في منهم توفوا
اضطروا الاحياء اضطروا ان هم ياكلوا يعني
كانت قصه
رهيبه جدا
والناس اللي هم
عدوا في التجربه دول لسه لسه عايشينه يعني
في متقدمين في السنه لسه عايشينه بيطلعوا
يتكلموا على القصه دي برده يعني ملهمه جدا
انت مرات بهذا النوع من التجارب الكلاسيز
هذه اللي اخذتها هل فادتك يعني وقت لما
تيجي حزت المشكله المصيبه يعني بتكون
مفيده
لو اكون امن جدا فانا بقول ان هي بتساعد
الواحد عشره عشرين في الميه لان مثلا اللي
احنا كنا بنعمله في جزء منه ان احنا ازاي
ان احنا نطلع القارب المنطقي وازاي ندخل
جواه وازاي كلام من ده كنا بنعمل ده في
حمام سباحه لان طبعا ان انت تعملي يعني
تقسيم
يعني ان يكون في عاصفه ده هيكلف الافات
وعشرات الالاف من الدولارات فالواحد دايما
بيتعلم السكيل نفسها بس مش بيعرف ان هو
يعمل الموضوع كله فما فيش عامل تجربه
نفسها فانا واحد بيكون متمرن على ده لازم
ان هو يعمل الكورس وكلام من ده لكن في
النهايه هو لازم يدخل في
المكان نفسه ويعيش تجارب حياتيه في ايام
اسابيع لحد ما يبقى عنده الموضوع ده لما
يحصل ما بيكونش بيفكر فيه ولكن بيحصل
بالفطره عمر البنت اكبر البنت اللي هي
يعني حمت اخوانها ويعني مرت فيهم يعني في
التجربه هذه كلها اسمها
[موسيقى]
عمر سمره شكرا لك
الم من جديد الغردقه والقرش الغردقه عنوان
من الخميس للسترند على المنصات والسبب
حادثه السائح الروسي اللي انهت حياته سمكه
قرش هو بيسبح في احد الشواطئ هناك السائح
كان بيسبح على بعد عشره امتار عن الشاطئ
وهاجمته سمكه قرش من نوع قرش النمرته لها
اربعه امتار ووزنها 900 كيلو وانهت حياته
ووزاره البيئه المصريه فورا ارسلت فريق
لسيد سمكه القرش اللي هاجمت الشاب وقالت
في بيان انه تمكن الفريق من صيدها وتم
نقلها للمعمل لفحصه وجمع المعلومات
المطلوبه لتحديد اسباب الهجوم وقالت انه
راح تصدر بيان بعد ما تنتهي من اعمال فحص
القرش وامرت باغلاق الشواطئ لغايه ما تتم
عمليات المسح والتاكد انه المكان في غيره
الفيديو طبعا كان قاسي جدا جدا وما حنقدر
نع لكم باي شكل لكن من وقت القصه واحنا
شايفين بوستات وفيديوهات وتعليقات فيها
تساؤلات عن كيف ممكن الواحد يتعامل مع
القرش ونصائح وتعليمات ايش الواحد لازم
يسوي ومعلومات عن القرش ومتى يهاجم ومتى
لا كميه معلومات وتعليقات مو طبيعيه يعني
وكثير منها حتى كان متضارب يعني فقلنا
يعني انه خلينا نسمع من مختص والسيد حسن
الطيب مؤسس جمعيه الانقاذ البحري وحمايه
البيئه واللي عنده اكثر من اربعين سنه
خبره في المجال جاوبنا على هذه الاسئله
خلينا نسمع
عايز اقول بس رايي كده في قصه الهجمات
اسماك القرش بالنسبه للغواصين ما فيش اي
قلق على الغواص نهائي لان الغواصين بيجوا
من الخارج مخصوص عشان يتفرجوا على اسماك
القرش ويشوفوا السمك القرش زي ما بيشوفوا
فده بيبقى متعب بالنسبه له ما فيش اي
خطوره عليهم لان بيبقى نازل زيه زي القرش
سمكه لبس الغطس فما فيش مشاكل عليه نهائي
اما السباح والسنوركينج واللي بيعوم على
السطح ده لربما يكون في موقف اضعف من
الغطاس بكتيره قوي سمكه القرش دايما بتبص
للي فوق على السباحه اما تحت الميه عمرها
ما بتهاجم الا نادرا يعني نادرا لما
بتهاجم سمكه غواص اما بخصوص السباحه اللي
بيحب ينزل يسبح في الميه طبعا طول ما
بيكون في مجموعات مع بعض القرش زكي جدا
اسماك القرش زكيه ومش بتهاجم مجموعات
عمرنا ما شفناها دخلت على مجموعه الهاجمه
دايما بتعمل مناورات مناورات حتى في
الحادث اللي حصل في الغردقه عادل القرش ده
يعمل مناورات كتيره كان فيه اربعه خمسه
حواليه لما الاربعه خرجوا للبر حد من
الروس السياح كان بيقول قرش قرش اكولا
بينصح الناس يطلعوا اطلعوا في اربعه
استجابوا وطلعوا ما عدا الشاب ده الروسي
ما خرجش وما طلعش فهو كان بالنسبه
للقرش يعني صيد سمين واحد لوحده فقدري
يتهجم عليه ويجيبه فاحنا بنقول للناس
دايما اما بيبقوا في مجموعات
بيستمتعوا بالسباحه مع بعض ما فيش اي
مشاكل عليهم نهائي اما بالنسبه للناس اللي
بتفتي كل واحد له راي يقوله لكن هو ده
المتبع عندنا في مجال الغوص بصفه عامه كل
الدنيا بتيجي الغواصين
وبنسوق لسمكه القرش تعال علشان تشوف سمك
قرش عندنا في البحر الاحمر الغواصين وبيدر
دخل قومي للبلد بيدعم
السياحه فوجود سمكه القرش ضروره ليست فقط
للبيئه البحريه
بل ايضا للسياحه دعم للسياحه فوجوده ضروري
جدا في البيئه البحريه
شركه متى صاحبه التطبيقات الاشهر
والمردوده الماديه الاعلى او الاعلى اعلنت
عن تطبيق جديد بيشبه تويتر وقالت انه هذا
ردا على تويتر التطبيق عرضه كبير مسؤوليه
المنتجات في الشركه على الموظفين واسمه
داخليا في الشركه
وفي حال ابصر النور رح يكون اسمه
واللي بيشوف صور التطبيق حيظن انه تويتر
رسمي يعني شوفوا الالوان شوفوا مثلا
وتشوفوا التصميم مثل ما شايفين تماما مثل
تويتر والتطبيق مو محتاج لانشاء حساب جديد
ولا بيانات جديده ولا شيء لانه مرتبط
بانستجرام فاي مستخدم يقدر يعني يدخل اسمه
كمستخدم وباسورد انستغرامه ويصير عنده
حساب ويدخل على التطبيق ويصير جاهز بين
يده للاستخدام ومن بين الاخبار اللي تم
تداولها عن التطبيق الجديد انه بتتم
مناقشه فكره جد كثير المشاهير اللي
بيدوروا على تطبيق سهل الاستخدام وبيتصل
بالامان والمصداقيه علشان يشتركوا في
التطبيق ومن بينهم الاعلاميه والمحاوره
الشهيره اوبراون فري والدلاله طيب اما
بالنسبه لتاريخ طرح التطبيق فقالت متى انه
عمليات البرمجه بدات في يناير وانه راح
تطرحوا باسرع وقت ممكن للامانه طبعا هذه
مو اول مره بنشوف محاوله لاستنساخ تويتر
يعني عندنا تروت سوشيال مثلا من قبل نحاول
وعمل نفس الشيء ما حقق يعني نفس النجاح
المحققوته تويتر او عدد المستخدمين لكن
خلينا نشوف عاد ترد لما ينزل ايش راح يعمل
يمكن تكون حظوظه مختلفه خصوصا انه مدعوم
من شركه كبيره مثل متى يعني
[موسيقى]
التحضيرات لعيد ميلاد الملك تشارلز الرسمي
في 17 يونيو شغاله على قدم وساق في
بريطانيا طبعا قلت عيد ميلاد او عيد ميلاد
الرسمي لانه في بريطانيا بيحتفلوا بعيد
ميلاد الملك مرتين مره في يوم الميلاد
الفعلي وفي حاله الملك تشارلز هو 14
نوفمبر ومره رسميا في تاريخ 17 يونيو اللي
ضف موعد عرض عسكري ثانوي اسمه
مو هنا الخبر ترى هذه المقدمه بس امس
وخلال حضور امير ويلز ولي عهد بريطانيا
الامير ويليام الاخيره للحفل سقط ثلاث
جنود على الارض مغمى عليهم والسبب درجات
الحراره العاليه اللي وصلت ل 30 درجه
مئويه
في بريطانيا 30 تعتبر درجات حراره يعني
عاليه هذا موضوع اخر على جنب نتناقش فيه
في يوم ثاني يعني على العموم هذا غير انهم
طبعا هم لابسين ثقيل جدا وطواقي من الجلد
واقفين ساعات عفوا طواقي من الفرو ووقتين
ساعات
[موسيقى]
على الارض ورجع وقف وكمل عزف ومثل ما
شفتوا مشاهدينا اللي بيطيح ما بيقرب عليه
احد من زملائه الانقاذ بيجي من برا من
عناصر مو مشاركين في العرض وهذا جزء من
البروتوكول ومو اول مره نشوف مقاطع او
لحظات من هذا النوع خاصه
[موسيقى]
في جنازه الملكه اليزابيث في حوادث اخرى
شفناها ايضا امام القصور على العموم
مشاهدينا احنا وصلنا الى ختام حلقه اليوم
انا اعود القاكم بكره ان شاء الله في امان
الله